hi I'm Janelle Ynez a mom of three kids
and I went to see pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales and i
thought it was a pretty good movie
here's my bottom line how did it seem
yes I struggled a little cuz it's a
pirate movie but there's love and it's
fighting for what you believe in and
it's lots of fun
Jack Sparrow is a whole yael de bonus
and scare factor yes the pirate movie
guys so yes there was some violence and
it was a little scary not too scary but
it was scary maybe a little scary for
some shoes it's a pirate movie I said
that right sex and romance
two kisses that being in bad language if
you consider winch and horologist bad
language and yes otherwise nuff horology
is the study of time guys from Attica
drinking drugs and smoky yes Jacksboro
was drunk the entire movie whether you
saw him drinking or not he was drunk I
enjoyed the movie I had not seen any of
the Pirates of the Caribbean movies
surprisingly I know but I hadn't and I
felt like even though I hadn't seen any
of them I didn't feel like I missed
anything like I caught up like for me
it's not like a new story a new time I
don't think that my 14 year old would
have liked it I do you think that my 11
year old would have loved it in all of
Jack's serial shenanigans for sure now
there were some scary parts where I kind
of jumped out of my seat with the little
ghostly pirates they were freaky but
cool at the same time oh my goodness in
the way that Captain Salazar hair just
was continuously moving and flowing like
if I could walk through the streets of
LA with my hair moving like that honey I
don't know what would jump all Pirates
of the Caribbean dim until no tells is
rated pg-13 but I love it my living
Europeans
I'm generally men and that is the
gartner so I got to talk a little ladder
over all of that noise thanks for
watching mom's movie minute and I will
see you the next time
pumpkin gocator pumpkin
you